hi everyone in this video we're going to
practice using the mass number equation
this equation represents the fact that
the mass number of an atom is equal to
its number of protons plus its number of
neutrons
let's use the mass number equation to
answer the following question
how many neutrons are in an isotope of
sodium with the following notation
to answer this question we'll first need
to rearrange our mass number equation to
solve for the number of neutrons pause
the video and take a moment to try this
for yourself
the rearranged equation is as follows
the number of neutrons equals the mass
number minus the number of protons
based on this notation we know that this
sodium isotope has a mass number of 23
and an atomic number of 11.
if we subtract the atomic number 11 from
the mass number 23 we're left with 12
which is the number of neutrons in this
sodium isotope
okay more practice this time with an
isotope of platinum
how many neutrons does this isotope have
based on the following notation PT
hyphen 195.
again we'll need to use the rearranged
mass number equation to solve for the
number of neutrons
this particular notation provides the
chemical symbol of platinum and its mass
number
we can look up platinum on the periodic
table to find its atomic number which is
78 meaning that every platinum atom has
78 protons we can subtract the atomic
number 78 from the mass number 195 to
get
117. so this isotope of platinum has 117
neutrons